in all of human history yeah that's like  women bring less to the table nowadays  in terms  we have women on the table my guy  a table that's pretty is common no no no  no I'm not saying I'm not saying I'm not  saying  I'm not saying nothing I'm not saying I  was in pretty because anyone could be  pretty you could go and get plastic  surgery and be a [ __ ] pretty [ __ ]  you know what I mean yeah but for me  that's true it comes down to like women  and men provide different things so like  as a woman you provide I don't know  obviously everyone's got their own  mindsets but men provide like they are  providers as where woman they like they  cook they look after the children